[Musik]
fritz hauser begrüßen ohne wo sie sicher
wieder vorstellen für ihre circus ja
also von zell terror und von der
veterinäre größen an
märz gehen und wie heißt nämlich ihre
circus da wir genau mit dem namen will
die schweiz keine mitglieder und würden
eigennamen im alter von 62 jahren möchte
der einstige radsport held zusammen mit
seiner frau heidi seinen kindheitstraum
verwirklichen und einen zirkus gründen
klein aber fein soll er werden endlich
wieder circus harlekin den sie besuchen
um zu sehen was die konkurrenz so macht
es ist keine boombranche in die sie
einsteigen wollen
im gegenteil viele zirkusunternehmen
kämpfen ums überleben
[Musik]
aber die sehnsucht nach dem zirkus leben
ist stärker als alle bedenken naturell
linie ist eine diagnose fabrik gene
steuern machine for free lehrberuf a
nach b fahren wieder drüber liegen für
mich langweilig sie ich zufrieden
genommen
[Musik]
das ist vielleicht irgendein ist
comedian tramführer der verrückten traum
[Gelächter]
hat sie dann schon mal so einen betrieb
für einen betrieb für und der prävention
wie ruhig ich bin
[Musik]
dem alltagstrott entkommen und in eine
andere welt eintauchen
das werden die menschen auch in zukunft
wollen sind die branche überzeugt
und genau das bietet der zirkus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir fangen alena mensch erklärung
beschriftet und vögel immer noch anfang
2018 hat die braut einen ersten anlauf
genommen sich seinen traum vom zirkus zu
verwirklichen
beim circus royal führten er und seine
frau das bistro nach einem jahr trennte
man sich bereits wieder im unfrieden
nun wollen sie einen eigenen zirkus
gründen
damit möchte breu zurück auf die
siegerstraße
dorthin wo er als sportler war
neu gehört zu den erfolgreichsten
rennfahrer der schweiz
er gewann klassiker wie die sogenannte
züri metzgete
[Applaus]
und zwar auf das gesamtklassement der
tour de suisse
[Applaus]
aber dann sagt sekunde vorsprung im
gesamtklassement auch auf der bahn
brillierte der gelernte briefträger
sie sehen den recht vereinbar freuen was
finden sie gut an
[Musik]
in den 1980 er jahren eilte er von
erfolg zu erfolg und wurde gefahr für
seine sportlichen leistungen und für
seine treffen sprüche kurz prix war ein
star
[Musik]
ausrutscher waren selten war ein sieger
auch bei der legendären akteur ist sie
dabei an der tour de france wird das
stimmt das können wir jetzt selber frage
ist ein erster gast robert boyle wird
nach einer glücksfee spielen wieder zu
lässig im fußball den ich mir fragend
und gehört zum geschäft
unsere gastgeber ist der bad boy
[Applaus]
heute leben die branche in einem
wohnmobil passiert auf dem hof eines
befreundeten bauern das geht so darf 1
zu hören
ja die extreme veranstalte zahl
staubigen platz gezündet
1990 begann sein tiefer fall
davon hat er sich bis heute nicht erholt
telefone mit leben um 180 grad verkehrt
und bestimmte bist immer noch da ich bin
eigentlich verstanden
das ist zweimal gewonnen mehr ist
finanziell gut ging nämlich eine familie
gaddafi sei es den alliierten
über seinem sechs zimmer haus st gallen
mit blick auf den bodensee zogen dunkle
wolken auf
[Musik]
die idylle mit seiner damaligen frau
claudia und den beiden kindern mark und
denise wurde zerstört
[Musik]
preuß bruder ein banker wurde verhaftet
er hatte seine bank mit cleveren
transaktionen um über 60 millionen
erleichtert
[Musik]
und da beginnt das drama des bad boy
er hatte seinen bruder mehr als 500000
franken überwiesen aus erspartem und aus
der hypothek auf seinem eigenen haus
damit wurde er mit besitzer von sechs
liegenschaften im gesamtwert von rund 12
millionen franken werde aber möchte so
schnell als möglich aus diesem besitz
aussteigen um sein investiertes geld
wieder zu haben den wegen der
solidarhaftung riskiert er bei den
gegenwärtig tiefen immobilienpreisen bei
einem verkauf für viel geld haften zu
müssen was wir passieren mit ihnen also
wenn leonie schade und steht seitdem
verblasst sie hat ein treffen das ist
auch familie und decken wir sind recht
lebe mir einfach bekannt hätte er
bekannt mit den nach wie vor ohne sakko
hängt gewinn normal eine bewegung mit
accor können publisher einfach alle die
wacklige viel
broich hoffnung sich mit der bank leu
welche die häuser am teile seines
bruders übernommen hatte gütlich einigen
zu können war bald zerschlagen
ruiniert
wenn wir weiter so bankdirektor also
erfahrungen straße wie schon mächtig mit
dem 8
dann da da jetzt soll ich mit der band
kann ich ankam hat bei dir mit mehr
und wer jetzt mit mir erfahrenen
entgangen sind der große villa park city
eine firma seid dabei wenn sie einmal
probleme mit sie nur zu mir und wollen
die dem problem kabine und zudem kann
ich mich kaum jemand kennt nämlich
behandelte der lebt strecken dass sich
menschen hinter schweinehund zu nehmen
die der große menge und dich linie für
druck
was können ihre absolute niveau
heimmannschaft uhr bevor er brauchte
dringend geld um seine schulden
abzuzahlen
also fuhr er weitere trennen und wurde
zusätzlich entertainern
[Musik]
die sache müsse mache mir eigentlich
normal mit mach ich wäre nie im leben
nur wenig stand aber das sind denn die
erholen können muster machen dafür die
entscheidung getroffen die mir machen
und deshalb nun ja sage das wetter
funktioniert aber noch sieben jahre
unterwegs
nach silber und durfte ich den einfach
nur knapp flach die wie die trixie sofia
man kann jede woche zweimal gesehen denn
ist es den übergang so lustig und ich
hätte es mir sehr gerne und ich ich bin
nicht unbedingt auf der bühne stehen zu
mercks einfach einen auftritt ihre
schönste fünf minuten sein bevor sie
ruft regte an die sechste stunde
minister fünf minuten sind dem bin ich
fertig bin
und da ist nicht ganz klar
für die privatinsolvenz war er zu sturz
also sollte er damals rund 20000 franken
pro monat ab ein ende seiner schulden
macht trotzdem nicht in sicht
unsere bühne stadtlohn der gianni di
modrone mehr einfach da stände job und
die mythologie technisch eigentlich ein
mann für problem dass selbst dort zum
glück unterhalten
da ist ihm aber dass das moniert wir den
eu-ländern identität und es ist
schwierig sich also den depressionen
bedeutet sie hätte keine der head die
helbraer selber nicht empfunden als die
passion amerika einfach nicht knacken
zwischenzeitlich verschwand von der
bildfläche
2001 tauchte er wieder auf
er trat als aushängeschild eines wild
west hotels im sankt gallischen
oberbüren auf zusammen mit seiner
damaligen partnerin betriebe eine art
sanitätsposten im notstandsgebiet
menschliche triebe lebe nach einem guten
jahr zog es sich wieder aus dem
sexgeschäft zurück das große geld das er
und ein investor im hintergrund sich
erhofft hatten war ausgeblieben und der
einstige sportheld zur witzfigur
geworden
[Musik]
missbräuchlich glauben ich hoffe nur
dass er an dem buch von ihm sagten chefs
bin dass er aus heinsberg bei twitter
und facebook
jetzt bist du blind macht mir doch karte
munition der jungs die die verwaltung
nehme mit ehefrau und die schmutz der
erste schwimmer
london sid die bei spielenden huf
verlangen hörmobil haben wir mit rinde 9
bft größten schienen wieder alles
beherbergen können normale job mache
wenn ich habe mit denen bank gesagt
tribals und kosmetika messe zahle mit
einer normalen ii kommen wir es gerne
gegangen und die zeit mittwoch regelt
die zeit rinnt und die falk lüke sich
schon klar aber ideal in dem zehn punkte
oder psychisch dafür mit bestpreis
öffentliche auftritte gibt den zusehends
vom komischen ins tragische im alter von
49 jahren gab er ein comeback aus stehe
auf der offenen rennbahn in zürich
oerlikon
nach zwei erfolglosen saison trat er
wieder zurück immer noch hoch
verschuldet und ohne perspektive an
seiner seite inzwischen heidi die
seither mit ansehen muss wie ihr partner
belächelt oder gar ausgelacht wird
eingesperrt warten sie nur umfassend wie
resident genommen und die männer nicht
ganz das thema bienen und machen ohne
die lieblosen aufregendere so ich sagen
immer diskret weder etwas schlechter
schnitt mehr leute zum vergessen
im moment sind die preis ohne einkommen
sie leben von ihren reserven trotzdem
seien sie glücklich miteinander sagen
sie dann ist man immer wenn das problem
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen
[Gelächter]
wir sind halt nur schwierig ja schon gut
im spiel und macht alles mit um seinen
traum vom zirkus zu verwirklichen hat
grohe im internet ein crowdfunding
lanciert mindestens 50000 franken will
er so sammeln
optimal wäre 150.000 dafür rührt er nun
kräftig die werbetrommel
bis jetzt mit bescheidenem erfolg es
sind erst gut 5000 franken
zusammengekommen seien enttäusche gesagt
mein gang schnell
ich habe ein ambivalentes verhältnis zu
den medien am anfang seiner karriere
jubelten sie ihm hoch später war erich
fußabtreter trotzdem lieferte sich ihnen
jetzt wieder raus so richtig gemacht
nach rektor dieter hundt nennt man kein
lottospieler die clip vergesst den
mieter nicht noch mal dran
aber als sportler oder eben würde die
geschichte der musik liebe werden ich
völlig machtlos
[Musik]
er sei sogar sehr sensibel findet seine
frau die vielen tiefschlägen die hinter
den beiden ligen haben spuren
hinterlassen
vor allem bei ihm sagt sie als nicht
sehr wahrscheinlich hat man immer vor
ihm stehen verlangt
wieso aber nicht für e10
granit oder das gibt es nicht und ich
glaube paris nun forscher liefert in der
generation weisen ob sie die mutter das
kabarett das zur regeneration sind nur
funkel der nach einem heute so größer
und dar und ist durchaus nichts zeigen
und der wahl eher schwache männer sie
wohnen jetzt muss darüber reden und da
laufen
[Musik]
2013 meldete privatkonkurs an
er ist heute schuldenfrei und will sich
erneut in ein finanzielles abenteuer
stürzen
[Musik]
ortstermin mit der polizei in st gallen
auf der kreuzbleiche wie der zirkus bnd
jahr für mehrere wochen gastieren die
nötigen bewilligungen bekäme er nur das
geld fehlt noch alles andere ist bereit
wie fühle ich mich immer überzeugen dass
man die letzten signale bringen nicht
und sobald man zusagen für die er den
ruf die stark knopfdruck den ganz knapp
drüber minute den ko so dass er zuerst
in st gallen haut machen möchte ist kein
zufall hier ist pro jahr gewachsen
direkt gegenüber der kreuzbleiche die
zirkusse schlugen ihre zelte damals
direkt vor seiner haustür auf und
faszinierten den kleinen bord was hat
sich verträumt karlsruhe kostet sie das
ja eigentlich schon und zierkonsolen
immer während sie von mir einmal in den
zirkus als warst ja das macht sie wenn
ich neue können mit wir können machen
wir eigentlich was hat sie dann
fasziniert vom zirkus fasziniert wendig
und die show an dem meine tag startet
sehr konstant über nacht sind haben
nichts wieder verschwunden und die
faszinieren mich schon immer
und überhaupt alles mit zelt da ist wo
man gern camping macht im feld ich mehr
wohl
dezember mobil
es geht auch um sehnsüchte aus seiner
kindheit aber nicht nur möchte wieder
dorthin wo er auch sportler war als er
noch bejubelt wurde und nicht belächelt
in arbon der heimat seines fanclubs
wurde nach seinem grossen siegen aus
held empfangen mädchens mit dem zug
gefahren jugendstation woran ich stehe
und der grossartig du einen bonus steht
noch mit dem erstmal weise mit dem
lincoln mit einem oldtimer amerikaner
mark harmon der 84
denn im festzelt mit dem stab präsident
veloclub schönherr in regionen wie sind
sie sich davor wenn kleine könig können
wir dort stark waren und alle winken ihm
zu und witz gemacht wo gewöhnlich ohne
hätten
da fühlt man sich schon noch gehabt wer
möchte aus gewinner in erinnerung
bleiben nicht aus verlierer ich aufhören
schöner erfolg an die zwerge mit deren
erfolgsgeschichte noch einen abschließen
wir wären auch wirklich alles daran
setzen dass das ursachen
[Musik]